Veux pas que les paysans meurent
et que les migrants les remplacent.
Je ne veux pas que la République de la CMU, de la me,
de la CAF, euh,
des aides sociales,
de l'assistana
finissent par l'emporter sur la France du
travail et de l'effort.
Et enfin,
je ne veux pas, je ne veux plus, je ne supporte plus,
comme tant de français,
que les médias de gauche, que les lobbies LGBT,
que les juges rouges
nous impose leur euh, euh, propagande,
euh. Obsessionnel.
Il faut que les français
le neuf/06 prennent 1 bulletin de vote
marion-maréchal.
J'en finis juste.
Je pense que c'est très important pour dire,
on a encore le droit en France,
au vingt-et-unième siècle,
de, d'aimer Noël,
d'aimer notre roman national,
d'être blanc,
d'être chrétien, d'être juif, d'être hétérosexuel.
Qui vous en empêche ?
On a l'impression que vous êtes aujourd'hui 1 victime,
mais il n'y en a,
il n'y a que pour la minorité.
Vous êtes 1 victime aujourd'hui.
Ah, la majorité silencieuse, l'homme blanc,
l'homme blanc, chrétien, hétérosexuel,
juif, hétérosexuel,
celui qui vit à la. Moi, vous savez,
je vis dans 1 p'tit village de Sologne,
je euh. Roule au diesel et je me chauffe au fioul.
J'aime les chasseurs, les pêcheurs, les agriculteurs,
j'aime le bon vin,
j'aime la bonne viande.
On a plus le droit, avec tous ceux qui nous gouvernent.
Et bien il y est-il est temps de mettre fin à tout ça,
de reprendre le flambeau politique,
électoral de Philippe seigain, de Charles pasquois
et du. Euh, génial Philippe devilier,
qui, tous les vendredis d'ailleurs, nous éclaire
et nous donne Le Cap.
Et pour cela, j'appelle les français
à se mobiliser pour marion-maréchal, le neuf/06.